you
hi everyone it's Jerry I just got paired
up here I'm playing a three two time
control game okay so let's see what we
could do here I'm going to review this
game afterwards with stockfish so we'll
see where all the mistakes are made
let's go with the Kings Indian and I'm
gonna try to pin okay no I'm going with
the same ish where there's a mesh let's
see hmm I don't want a castle just yet
I'm gonna play this line with knight c6
a6 rook b8 and b5 hmm I don't know if
there's a big difference between move
orders here actually I think if rook
here the knight gets a kick and maybe
the bishop snips the pond so I think
this then rip be a and then b5 okay so
they're clearly going for a dark square
bishop exchange mm-hmm I don't know if I
really fear that so much let's see
should I still follow through rook b8
hmm I have a couple ideas in mind here I
think the computer would just castle but
it has no fear of some crazy attack so
what about you know I think that would
be maybe a bit premature
castles Bishop h6 I don't think I have
to worry about that because of pawn push
hmm rook b8 yeah I'm gonna go with rook
via in fact no you can't do this right
away cuz it be dropping this let me let
me follow through let me get an in
position to play this I have already
done this move so let's try to be a
little bit consistent I guess we could
say so if Knight here to reinforce this
point this is a moment to maybe play b5
my night when kicked will hop into this
Square
so let's see what white does other
considerations or maybe h4 just
caveman-style there we go
caveman I think I want to stop that
altogether yeah let's let's play h5 so
this is ruled out altogether
and I think this might now be a reason
now that I have this pawn up I don't
know that I want to castle so quick I
think I want to take this guy out yeah I
don't want him arriving on be our g5
that could be quite annoying I'm gonna
take him out and let's see do I play
this right away maybe I do this move
Knight here and then this is prepping
this advance I think this is a good idea
yeah let's run with it
so now I'm hitting d4 twice is defended
twice if pawn push it does give up these
nice dark squares e5 and c5 queenside
castle I might do this move even at the
even if it's dropping upon I get some
play the bishop combined with the rook
pointing at b2 can be quite difficult to
defend hmm they cannot kingside castle
okay now I think this is an excellent
move it's just the right way to go about
it
now that the bishops on this square when
a knight arrives here he cannot be
challenged right away so on d5 Knight
here and then I'm even in a position to
lend support or even break at this
square with c6 or some combination of c5
and b5 they got about a 30-second
advantage but we have the increment what
would I do on Bishop g5 not quite sure
maybe I could just welcome a dark square
Bishop exchange actually Bishop takes
Knight takes or Queen takes I think
Knight takes is fine and I'm getting
into these dark squares so
I'm kind of happy with how things have
turned out so far I'll see what the
suggestion is for the white side because
I know they could have been putting up a
much more difficult fight
I think getting into this d4 square is a
great success know they're about a
minute five here so let's see how they
work around this beast on the d4 square
I have pressure here okay where's the
king in ago I'm gonna still keep my
options open this is for as long as I
keep my rook here this makes the g4
advance you know no problem really I
could take and then take on this square
bishop here I'd gladly go for a dark
square Bishop exchange I think my idea
is pretty straightforward here I'm
looking at c5 and b5 maybe maybe b5
right away they're less than 30 seconds
mm okay c5 c6 and b5 okay dark square
Bishop exchange I'm fine without Knight
or queen recapture probably my queen I
like keeping an eye on this square so I
have good dark square control here Queen
here I could take and then play f6 now I
could now not do this move drop the
night I think I play c5 no he is really
anchored in there Queen f4 might be an
idea now on my next move Queen takes
pawn takes and now he's secured and I
have a new square available for this
night my idea here is b5 and I have up
early all the place so they're gonna
play f4 I have this reinforced I think I
need to get on with this attack here is
there
way to stop this f4 advance oh there
they are really going to have to live
off the increment I could take this pawn
and I'm on the Queen actually hmm Knight
takes pawn I could do that
and why not
Bishop takes
takes and then maneuver a night into
this square okay less than 20 hmm I'm
going to not go for that I like my night
way too much to go pond hunting okay now
I'm definitely taking here because this
is falling now I will take that and then
get back here they could take this pond
let's get out of the way they're not
gonna take this poem and move them I
have this secure look here next can be a
great pain I don't want a castle oh I
have to overprotect this point well I
didn't even see that
I have this square now okay dark square
control I'm ready to take the bishop in
the land of forth they missed that time
pressure this is GG now hmm
okay let's just consolidate over protect
this and then my queen is free to do
some other dangerous things like snip
this pawn and then this should be game
or this will be game over with the
increment just mopping up Hans now get
rid of the center pawns
they'll probably resign right about here
seeing that this is falling we'll see
what stock fish has to say after this I
guess we're just gonna play this one out
I don't have to watch over f7 anymore
rook activity and where's the mate okay
the farm at me here no stalemates
let's check and mate next million two
million won okay let's see what stock
fish has to say about this game here so
I think white really messed up at some
stage let's see I don't think there's
anything wrong with what they're doing
so far the more testing try mm-hmm maybe
right here already playing Age 4 that's
fine computer doesn't have any issue
it's somewhere around point for one of
the top suggestions is Bishop d3 and
then get the knight here next to
reinforce d4 sometimes this knight can
travel over here to reinforce this
square that might have been an idea as
well an immediate Knight here here here
and then Bishop to e2
sometimes the knight does take that path
okay h4 I think it's important I stopped
these this idea of h5 there's nothing
wrong with this reply does white really
lose something with this move Knight
there I like to give it a little bit of
time to think here mmm
still says it's quite quite all right
here still about a slight advantage 0.4
advantage it likes playing a 5 right
here just immediately anything wrong
with Bishop takes Knight about 1/2 pond
advantage for white and still about 1/2
pond advantage okay it did not like this
move so hmm maybe this is the where
something is lost here yeah the
evaluation is dropping with that last
move
yeah now it's just about even they're
very very slight edge here for white
after Bishop to e2 the suggestion is to
queenside castle about a half pound
advantage within the continuation a five
and D takes e5 D takes e5 I do have this
square though King B 194 and then g4 I
guess you're gonna work around this pun
interesting I do have this square so
that's that's nice the computer really
likes white here close to a pawn
advantage that's surprising with this
nice control over the d4 square hmm okay
after Bishop d2 it's about even like c5
and now it's maybe it's already liking
black here
I felt like that just anchoring that
night in there and this is helping me
with a dark square control no dark
square Bishop c5 is fine and it doesn't
like this the two moves that are popping
up are to take here and b5 popped up for
a quick moment there likes black for
about a pawn advantage something just
did not feel right to be taking this
pawn there's just a wonderful piece here
on d4 I thought better to just open up
the B file play against the King was
anything missed from here I don't think
so
another thing I my queen is protected so
ideas of Queen here to pin my Queen
they're just not working I could get
back to the d4 square anything missed in
this one it's pretty clean once I have
this Knight here is just an animal very
very difficult to work around that
weakens the light squares he's trying to
get into b5 and this is where I panicked
a little bit I was ready to play King
here but that
Knight takes pawn but this is still
actually good but I guess a little bit
too scary for my taste here the king
could run over here I didn't want to
allow f7 to be taken so just
overprotected there's nothing wrong with
that and now this is game over pawn and
a half advantage and a knight here it's
just too much even ideas are just
sacrificing here after up there they had
his game over after it rook takes Bishop
what would have been better mm-hmm
best resistance is Queen e2 King g7 king
b1 not the happiest moves to have to
play here and then Queen b7 I guess
we're looking to pile up hmm it's
interesting and I thought the rook here
tripling up about rook h2f to a bit of a
mysterious move Queen c8 what would
happen after rook here just rook f8
there's even ideas of Queen here
offering a queen exchange putting
pressure on this point as well
interesting yeah just kind of collapse
we were in time pressure around this
point so that was pretty much the ball
game
but yeah once I got my knight here this
is the this was the big the the critical
point I guess you could say what to do
at this stage right here not Bishop to
e2 instead getting on with some
development and having this g4 ID in
mind he 5 here and then g4 and white is
still shooting for something here
looking to open up the position there
might even be some idea to push and then
play this move not certain of that but
uh you know this is I can't Castle for
sure castling here is just opening up
the G file so and eventually I think I
would feel like I would need to Castle
I'm a bit of a bit inconvenienced one
way to maybe view this is that for as
long as this pawn remains on g4
maintaining the tension I kind of don't
know what I should do with my kid
certainly can't Castle queenside stay in
the center can't castle this move might
be coming very soon
you know anyhow once I did get into d4
this is where it shifted the big shift
about the 12th movement to the game here
and it was very difficult to work around
that night on d4 he was going nowhere
if he was taken out he'd end up I would
end up here with a passed pawn connected
past pawn so but okay as usual feel free
to leave any comments in the comment
section below to this video and as
always I hope you got something out of
it take care bye
you